not hancock therapy health secretary
well up until now the opposition has
been relatively supportive of the
government's actions on coronavirus is
that about to change or listening into
that interview was Labour's shadow
health secretary Drunken Ashworth who
joins us now from Leicester thank you
very much for being on the program we've
just heard from that Hancock who says
the government is going to be looking at
bring in emergency powers next week that
he's been working with you on some
suggestions what kind of thing can we
expect to see what can I just say at the
outset the we support the national
efforts it's a deal where to contain and
delay the spread of this virus people
are concerned people are worried people
are worried about what to do for for
their elderly relatives how to keep
their loved ones safe and we think it
would be entirely responsible of us as
an opposition to make this a sort of
party political thing but equally would
not be responsible of us not voice the
concerns that are being voiced more
widely in the scientific community not
to probe the government not to ask
questions we do that not to undermine
the government because we want the
government strategy to succeed but we
think it's important that we can all
reassure ourselves that the government
is taking the correct approach let me
just give you one quick example the
World Health Organization is saying that
we should continue testing and can end
contact tracing they're saying that is
the best way to break the chain of
contagion the UK government have taken a
different view that if you feel ill that
you just stay at home for seven days and
won't be tested many people are saying
to me that they need a covert 19 test if
they're ill because they need to know
whether they should be interacting with
other people in a few weeks I mean if
you've got elderly relatives and you
take seven days off work now because
you've got a cough what happens in a
month's time if you've got a coffee ghin
do you take another seven days off work
people need to need certainty so I just
need to understand better why the
government is taking a different
approach based on its science from other
countries and I think that's why it's so
important that all the scientific
modeling for example is published we
called for that last week the government
of have said they are going to publish
it because
we have to take the public withers on
this and on that more broadly is utterly
unacceptable for government sources
whatever to be briefing journalists
overnight on issues which are very very
fundamental to how we deal with this
virus very fundamental to how our
society is going to operate in the
coming weeks if things have changed
since Thursday and things are changing
quickly things have changed since the
Prime Minister's press conference on
Thursday then really the Prime Minister
should be doing another press conference
today and explaining why things have
changed you mentioned there about how
the government seems to be taking
different action to some of what we're
seeing in other countries or for example
school closures travel plans
non-essential businesses such as pubs
and restaurants staying open do you
think we should be doing more in terms
of closing down at these kind of
institutions well I think we need to
understand better why we seem to be
taking a slightly different approach to
some of our comparative countries and
nations internationally people are
asking us why we are not taking these
more far-reaching stringent measures
people in the science community of
asking that the issue is that it's not
for me to adjudicate on the science and
come down in favor of one set of
scientists are another but I think it's
important that when people are raising
concerns that the government modeling is
is published and it can be scrutinized
and they have a clear explanation so
that's on the science more broadly
though I do have more broader concerns
about the government's preparations
generally we know that this that this
virus is going to be really a real
problem for them elderly and the
vulnerable in society it's going to be a
real problem for the poorest in society
we want to make sure that NHS has got
the resources it needs that our social
care services have the resources that it
needs that those who need to take time
off work have proper sick pay and are
not financially penalized for taking
time off work that that that our elderly
who were who who have been told to
isolate potentially for three or four
months I'm going to get the support that
they need in the wider community because
that's going to have
social implications these are the
questions that we really want to put to
the government and we need reassurances
that the government have a resourced
plan and a considered plan that can
maintain public confidence talking about
resources in the interview with Matt
Hancock he was saying that the provision
of ventilators is effectively the
priority now they've only got 5,000 they
need many times more that if you produce
the ventilator we will buy it no number
is too high some people listen to that
we'll be quite worried that we don't
have enough ventilators is the NHS
prepared well the NHS needs more
resources desperately I mean we have
stories of clinicians on the frontline
treating Kovac 19 patients who don't
have adequate protective masks and
goggles and clothing and so on we're
taught we know we don't have enough beds
in the NHS we certainly don't have
enough intensive care beds we need to
understand whether the government is
able to scale up the intensive care bed
capacity to levels that we hope levels
though many are suggesting that we need
we've been raising some for some time
now the point about ventilators and we
need to buy up those ventilators we
should have been doing that weeks ago
but of course ventilators need staff to
operate them so we need to understand
how staffing will be changing in the NHS
and many many NHS staff are getting in
touch with me privately because they are
desperately concerned they're hearing
reports from other health workers in
Italy they're seeing what's happening in
Italy where the health service look
looks like it is under intense strain if
not becoming overwhelmed and many NHS
staff are looking for urgent reassurance
that we won't be in that position I mean
in Italy is a g7 country and they've got
international aid paid aid body's like
MSF going in to help their efforts on
the front line and the NHS staff are
raising these issues with me directly
and I think ministers urgently urgently
need to reassure us that they have a
resourcing plan in place to support our
NHS staff who are on the front line in
this in
battle with coronavirus I just want to
go back to the very first question that
I asked you and Matt Hancock saying the
government will be seeking a merger
sorry I didn't answer sorry in
Parliament next week yeah I'm good I'm
going to make sure you do answer this
one before you go and we've been working
with the House Secretary on these
emergency powers what kind of thing
could we see well we of course we want
to cooperate because this is not a party
political issue but we will we will be
voicing our concerns we will be asking
the government to reassure us that the
some of the very stringent powers
they're hoping to put on a statue but
what emergency police taking used are
under consideration well I mean well I
mean the things that you've seen in the
newspapers a other things that they're
talking about I mean quarantine powers
over what but actually some of the
quality powers are already on the
statute book because we had to we had to
amend the regulations last week and but
what we're really concerned about is
issues like sick pay people are who
people who are low paid and who need to
take time off work no I can't penalize
for it because they'll be asked to make
a choice between financial hardship and
their health and that is not acceptable
okay and then just finally well we've
got you and lots of people are very
worried about food supply they'll be
going to their local Asda Tesco
Sainsbury's Waitrose seeing empty shells
waiting for weeks for a delivery slot
that they can book and people selfish
who are stockpiling some of these
essential item items I don't know well
no I don't think matter people that
people are worried and I think the
broader issue point is is we really need
a mass coordinated effort I mean I was
very fortunate in many ways that I got
that I worked in Downing Street for
Gordon Brown at the time of the
financial crash Gordon Brown grips that
issue and led an international effort on
it we need another big coordinated
international effort on this because
certain see is everything people need
advice and this virus spreads quickly
and it exploits ambivalence we don't
want any ambiguity people just want
clear advice not briefings to
journalists
overnight the Prime Minister should
out there daily telling speaking to the
nation and explaining why things are
changing I appreciate this is
fast-moving but that what we've seen
with the panic by hanging is a
reflection of the uncertainties that is
out there which is why I would really
urge the prime minister to be more on
the front force I'm not trying to be
sort of you know scoring points for the
sake of it but people want about
certainty and they want to be reassured
that government has a grip that was the
big lesson we learned when we were in
governor government and Gordon Brown
responded to the financial crash in 2008
thank you very much Jonathan ash with
that laying out Labor's side the story